today on the matt walsh show disney
decides that peter pan
is not appropriate for young children
due to its racism
we seem to develop some very strange
ideas in our culture about what is and
is not appropriate for kids so we'll
talk about that also five headlines
including
milo coming out as ex-gay the left says
he's not allowed to do that apparently
and a new york times journalist says
online harassment has
quote destroyed her life in our daily
cancellation we'll talk about the famous
musician who apologized
and stepped down from his band after
committing the sin of
reading a book all of that and more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know when running a business one of
the things that can really kill you one
of the issues that's
going to be the most difficult to deal
with and business owners uh will tell
you this
is is hr issues hr issues can kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
and hr manager salaries on top of it
aren't cheap an average salary is about
70
dollars a year it's a lot of money that
you're dishing out as a business owner
bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e was created
specifically for small businesses you
can get a dedicated hr manager
craft hr policy maintain your compliance
all for just 99
a month with bambi you can change hr
from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email real time chat they're
there for you they can do what you need
done
from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business
this is not a cookie cutter approach
this is customized and they're doing all
this for just 99
a month month to month no hidden fees
cancel any time so
go to bambi.com walsh right now to
schedule your free hr audit that's
bambi.com
walsh spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash walsh it has of course
been decided by the people who
decide these things that the the issue
most urgently requiring our attention
right now is that of offensive cartoons
even or especially cartoons that have
been around for decades and
never really offended anyone until right
now we have now a new salvo in this
newly launched war on animated
characters ktla.com has the story it
says disney plus has removed
several movies including dumbo peter pan
the aristocats and swiss family robinson
from children's profiles on its service
over negative depictions and stereotypes
the walt disney company had previously
placed content warnings
on the films for quote negative
depictions and or mistreatment of people
and people and cultures in october but
now it has removed access to the films
by children under seven
according to ktla sister station wtvo in
rockford illinois
adults with disney plus accounts can
still access the films with the content
warnings which appear on screen for
about 10 to 12 seconds
before the unedited content that
advisory reads in part this program
includes negative depictions and or
mistreatment of people or cultures
these stereotypes were wrong then and
are wrong now rather than remove this
content we want to acknowledge its
harmful impact
learn from it and spark a conversation
to create a more inclusive future
together
okay now any confused users of the
streaming service are sent to
the stories matter page on their website
to learn more about why children under 7
must be insulated from this
objectionable content
if you're curious the explanation they
give for peter pan is
this is what they say the film portrays
native people in a stereotypical manner
that reflects neither
the diversity of native peoples nor
their authentic cultural traditions
it shows them speaking in an
unintelligible language and repeatedly
refers to them as redskins an offensive
term
peter and the lost boys engage in
dancing wearing headdresses and other
exaggerated tropes
uh peter pan and lost boys are
culturally appropriating
those little bastards i mean literally
they're bastards
um anyway this is a this is a big
problem you know you have to admit you
don't want
the movie about a magical boy who flies
around with a fairy named tinkerbell and
fights a pirate whose hand was eaten by
a crocodile
with a clock in its belly to have any
absurd or silly depictions of native
americans
i mean well the depiction of everyone in
the movie is absurd and silly
it's a cartoon that used to be
like the whole point of a cartoon
everyone is a caricature
everyone is ridiculous all of the
depictions
are cartoonish because again
it's a cartoon why are you looking for
authenticity in an animated film made
for kids in 1953
but this is a reasonable question and
you cannot expect reasonable answers
in an age of unreason by the way it's
worth noting the reason that um
swiss family robinson had to be removed
from the site of children disney says
the pirates who antagonize the robinson
family are portrayed as a stereotypical
foreign menace
many appear in yellow face or brown face
and are costumed in an exaggerated and
inaccurate manner
with top-notch hairstyles robes and
overdone facial makeup and jewelry
reinforcing their barbarism and
otherness
inaccurate an inaccurate representation
of
whom exactly for for my memory of the
movie and it's been a long time i admit
but
these are just generic pirates with no
specified cultural background
and if the foreign pirates and swiss
family robinson representing four in
menace
then why aren't we castigating peter pan
because of captain hook representing a
white menace again reasonable questions
unreasonable age now people who are
determined to miss the point
or distract from it will respond to all
of this with a kind of a scoff and say
well
why do you care so much about these
cartoons why are you making such a big
deal about it
the answer of course is that i am not
the one making a big deal about it i
made nothing at all out of peter pan
or dr seuss or pepe le pew or any of the
rest of it
these are innocent and harmless things
that i enjoyed as a child
and my children enjoy now that's the
extent of the deal
i made out of it i never thought never
gave peter pan a second thought
i'm not the one doing that it is disney
and the media and the left generally
that have decided to make an issue out
of these things they're the ones who
decided to to find deep
moral significance and all these
different things but here the left again
pulls its favorite maneuver which i'm
always pointing out they make a mountain
out of a molehill
and then accuse us of blowing everything
out of proportion when we simply object
to their blowing it out of proportion
the other counterpoint will be that um
that will be made
about this latest development with
disney is that the films can still be
viewed
you know your child can still watch them
they haven't been erased
right they're just not on the children's
profiles
um they're they're being put behind kind
of a parental filter
okay well to that i respond in two ways
number one
for now for now peter pan still exists
but
anyone who's been paying it the
slightest bit of attention
already knows where this is headed give
it another few months and these films
will be taken out of
circulation entirely i i i don't need to
look into the future to know that
guaranteed that will happen after all
disney has itself said
that the movies are hateful and racist
disney is saying that
for now they hope to have their woke
cake and eat it too
labeling their own content racist but
still making money off of it but that's
not going to last for long
it can't last for long the precedent has
already been set
uh number two
and by the way just backing up there for
a minute what's what's gonna if i if i
were to try to look in the future a
little bit
i think what's to happen is you're going
to start having retail outlets
that say uh well we're not going to
carry
peter pan you know merchandise anymore
we're not going to sell the kids book
bag with the peter pan
uh image on it because it's it's from a
racist movie
and you know someone's some big retail
outlet's gonna say that target or
somebody
uh and then when that happens then
disney is gonna take all those movies
away because
then there's no reason for them to have
them the way they make their money on
something like peter pan
is through the merchandise if they can't
sell the merchandise anymore
um then then there's no reason it and
then they'll take their stand and say
you know what actually this stuff is
totally hateful we're not gonna
let you watch it at all so that's the
first point
second the main point it's not that the
movies aren't available
the main point isn't even about these
specific movies or dr
seuss or looney tunes there's a larger
principle at work here a number of
larger principles that matter
one of them is this as a culture we are
adopting a very
backwards inverted idea about the nature
of
childhood and what sort of things are
appropriate for children
as has been pointed out many times by
myself and others the very people who
have panic over the objectionable
content
in innocent children's cartoons will
defend with passionate intensity
the sewage spewed into our kids ears and
minds by modern pop artists
and modern pop culture generally they'll
mock us
for worrying that 12 year old girls are
listening to songs like [ __ ]
while in the next breath insisting that
great damage is being done
to these same children by like a cartoon
french skunk
reveals a deep confusion about what
sorts of things
children are equipped to handle what
kind of content they can process
mentally and what they can't and if i'm
wrong about any of that i'm only wrong
in calling this the result of confusion
rather than rather than a deliberate
effort to subvert and corrupt our
children
and in fact let me back up and say i was
wrong about that it's not confusion it
is deliberate
but it gets worse consider that disney
is a full-on proponent an advocate for
gender theory what this means is that
the company believes
and many on the left believe that a
five-year-old
is old enough to choose his own gender
but not old enough to watch peter pan
a boy in kindergarten has the mental
capacity to become a girl if he
if he so chooses but does not have the
capacity to watch
swiss family robinson the goal here is
to
entirely alter our view of
childhood innocence so that
they can destroy childhood innocence
without us noticing that's the point
if they get us focusing on something
else if they get us focusing on
protecting
the innocence of of our kids uh with
regards to peter pan and looney tunes
and all this kind of
totally innocuous stuff then they can
set out
doing their you know corrupting our kids
and we're not going to notice because
we're going to feel like well
you know we're we're really um manning
the fort here and then we're protecting
our kids because we're making sure they
don't watch peter pan
if all goes to plan and it is so far
they'll have a generation of children
who are emotionally and psychologically
destroyed
corrupted beyond recognition and all of
the adults
will look at these kids and see what
they've done
and what they've allowed to happen and
still feel proud
because at least the kids were protected
from dr seuss
and peter pan let's get now to our five
[Music]
headlines
before we get to five headlines you know
hiring as a business owner finding a
right candidate
um hiring someone the person finding the
person you're looking for and hiring
them
can be very complicated so what you have
to do is take advantage of places that
make it easier for you take advantage of
the services they're going to take
some of that burden off your shoulders
you've got enough to deal with already
finding great candidates to hire could
be like
well trying to find a needle in a
haystack sure you could post your job to
some job board but then
all you could do is hope the right
person comes along which is why you
should try
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com well zip recruiter
does the work for you when you post a
job on zip recruiter it gets sent out to
over a hundred top job sites with one
click then
zip recruiters matching technology finds
people with the right skills and
experience for your job and
actively invites them to apply you get
qualified candidates
fast you're not just putting it out
there into the ether and hoping that
someone finds it
so while other services may overwhelm
you with applications to sift through
zip recruiter finds you what you're
looking for
the needle in the haystack and right now
you can try ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
walsh that's ziprecruiter.com w-a-l-s-h
just go to
zip recruiter dot com slash walsh zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
number one there's a crisis on the
border well there's always been a crisis
it's worse now
uh a surge of illegals coming over
flooding the system ending up in cages i
mean not cages uh what are we calling uh
detainment
facilities um it's almost like
all of this could have been predicted uh
almost
it it it always seems to happen with
democrats that's why maybe you could
predict it cause this is the way it
always goes
if you send the message that you're weak
on border security and immigration
enforcement
you'll end up with a lot more illegal
immigration to enforce or to not enforce
as the case may be
so here's jen saki um dodging
i was going to say addressing the issue
but not so much addressing it as dodging
it yesterday let's watch
there are reports out there that the
number of unaccompanied migrants
detained at the border has tripled in
the last two weeks to 3200
plus is that number accurate i'm not
going to confirm numbers from here
obviously the department of homeland
security and others are oversee the
programs and the engagements that happen
at the border
i will say that there are a couple of
reasons i know um are asked about
our kind of change in policy but there
are a couple of reasons
why we think people are coming to the
border of course
individuals are fleeing countries where
individuals and families are
you know they're fleeing prosecution
fleeing violence fleeing economic
hardships and other things
the region has also experienced two
hurricanes in the fall
putting further stress on the conditions
in these countries and the circumstances
that are facing individuals and all this
is taking place during a global pandemic
that has impacted other countries
economies placing undue hardships on its
people just as it did
in the united states so there are also a
range of factors that are leading
individuals to come to the border
why won't you confirm that number that's
a very important number
i i i we've been very clear that there
is an increase
that there are more children coming
across the border than we have
facilities for
at this point in time those numbers are
tracked by the department of homeland
security so i'm certainly i'm just
suggesting that you talk to them about
specifics
from the numbers so she's not going to
confirm i i i
if i didn't hear her wrong i think what
she said unless i misheard
uh i think she said that the illegals
are coming here to flee
to flee prosecution is that what she
said
now i'm pretty sure she meant
persecution but prosecution was a little
bit of a freudian slip there because
in fact as donald trump famously said
you know when he was announcing his
campaign back in 2015 or 16
um many of them that are coming here are
criminals
so they are actually fleeing prosecution
so if that's what you said that was a
that was
an example of accidentally telling the
truth but when you think about this you
know that the main thing i always go
back to with
the situation on the border what annoys
me the most
and of course we always get this from
democrats where all of their policies
even though their policies often lead to
directly lead to
immense human suffering they still will
say
it's it's compassionate we're the
compassionate ones
we have the compassionate policies
with immigration or at the economy or
anything else
looking over all of the just just the
the
devastation wrought by those same
policies
no this is not compassion you know
what's happening at the border right now
it's not compassion to
allow that to happen to set the stage
for that
and in fact probably i don't want to get
splitting hairs too much but probably we
should move away from the word
compassion
when we're talking about policies in
general
because really compassion and this is a
word that's been that's been overused to
the point of
of meaninglessness like so many other
words but the word compassion actually
means
co-suffering that's what it means and uh
so so what
what compassion actually means if you're
really compassionate towards someone
it means that you're you're suffering
alongside them you're taking on in some
sense they're suffering you're doing
something for them
um and and so supporting a policy
whatever the policy is that's not an act
of compassion on your part
because you don't have to do anything it
requires no sacrifice on your on your
end
whatever your view is on immigration
most likely it's just a view that you
have it's
it's your opinion you're not actually
most of us not actually doing anything
one way or another so there's no
compassion
in supporting a policy that's the first
thing but so it's not really what
what policy is the most compassionate
the question is what policy is we should
be using words like
the most prudent what policy is the most
wise what policy
is most likely to minimize human
suffering
so we can start thinking in those terms
and it's pretty clear that having a
border
protecting that border enforcing our
laws
that is going to be the most prudent the
most wise thing to do and it's in the in
the long run going to
uh most minimize human suffering all
right number two cbs brought out a trans
journalist to talk about the issue of
trans people in sports
um and the republican state legislatures
that are trying to bar
men from women's sports those bigots how
dare they
actually the cbs tweet where i found
this video says republicans in at least
25 states have introduced over 60 bills
targeting trans youth
limiting access to school sports and
gender affirming health care now that's
totally wrong in every way every part of
that is wrong
this is the way it's framed by the media
but we hear
it's an anti-trans bill no it's not
if anything it's a pro-woman bill
um a pro-science bill a pro-sanity bill
but it's also in no way there are no
bills so far as i'm aware
someone can correct me if i'm wrong i
don't think there are any bills in the
works in any state anywhere
that would stop trans people from
competing in sports no one is trying to
do that i've never met any conservative
who advocates for that
i've never talked to a single
conservative who says you know what i
think we should just i think trans
people shouldn't be allowed to
compete in sports period
no if you're a biological male however
you identify
we're throwing up in the doors and
saying you are welcome to
try out and compete over here with with
other biological males
you're welcome in the bathroom with
other biological males well we welcome
all biological but it doesn't matter how
you identify
it's so that's a very equitable policy
to use the popular uh buzzword
so that's completely wrong but um
speaking of being completely wrong in
every way here's what the reporter says
about these policies
so many of these bills orion center
around transgender student athletes uh
what's the argument
for proponents of the bill which attempt
to exclude trans youth from teams that
align with their gender
identity and what evidence do they have
if any to support their claims
i i note that governor christie gnome of
south dakota has just
recently introduced a bill
yes exactly mississippi and south dakota
are the two states that look
like they're going to pass these bills
into law very soon
both governors both republican governors
have said that they plan to find these
bills
and the argument that lawmakers are
bringing to this
is that transgender inclusion in sports
would harm women's equality with harm
equality for girls
but i would note that as the associated
press has reported
they talked to over 24 lawmakers and the
majority of them
failed to bring evidence to actually
find examples within their state
to say this has been a problem we found
students who say this has been a problem
that's not to say there is zero evidence
is the lawsuit that i mentioned earlier
those three connecticut high school
runners said they were denied
scholarship opportunities
based on trans inclusion in sports
right so what the question was what
evidence do they have
what evidence do they do they possibly
have that says that uh
quote unquote trans girls shouldn't be
competing
in female sports what what what evidence
could they bring to the table i don't
know a biology textbook
that's all the evidence they really need
i mean i think they can still bring a
biology textbook to the table eventually
the biology textbooks will uh
you know will will eventually those
those books will go in the burn pile too
um
actual biology textbooks but as far as i
know right now
kids are basically still taught human
biology in school um
so that's it that's that's the evidence
it's an obfuscation what you heard there
that
the republicans in most of these states
they haven't been able to bring evidence
of girls really being harmed by these
policies
well if there's been no evidence of that
and that's not the evidence we need but
yet what the evidence we need again
is is simply the science of it to
establish
that girls are one thing boys are
another thing these are two categories
of people
boys have an unfair biological advantage
uh in principle and girl sports that's
why they don't belong there that's all
the evidence you need but
in terms of evidence of girls being
harmed by these policies
as was admitted there is some really
compelling evidence of that like in
states like connecticut
but in other states if there are no
examples of that yet it's because it
hasn't happened yet
and these laws are trying to stop it
from happening
the laws are looking to prevent this
thing from happening
the whole point is we don't want to wait
for the damage to be done we don't we
don't want to wait for a whole
uh generation of girls to be deprived of
athletic scholarships and all of that
and then we could circle back and say
see i told you
this is a foreseeable outcome and so
we're going to prevent that outcome
with these laws that's the point number
three from the new york post it says
right-wing provocateur
milo yiannopoulos has come out as ex-gay
announcing that he would
quote would like to help rehabilitate
what the media calls conversion therapy
over the next decade according
to the report the 36 year old british
political commentator
um declared himself no longer gay and
quote sodomy-free
in an interview with lifesite news
yiannopoulos
told the outlet that he is now leading a
daily consecration online to saint
joseph
now there's been a lot of chatter about
this online
what i'll say is first of all
the accusation is that this is all a
giant troll on milo's part
that's all this is he's looking for
attention i think that could be it i
don't know
how am i supposed to know
but also that's the point
how am i how are you supposed to know
the internet has simply
declared this is what they have declared
when i say the internet mostly the left
although not just the left a lot of
people on the right too from what i've
seen uh on social media
what what has been declared is that um
no milo's not allowed to do this
he's just he's not allowed to not be gay
anymore he can't that he can't make that
choice
and we in the public we know more about
milo's sexual orientation
uh than he does that's the attitude
from many in the public and it's
ridiculous
it also of course it's like there's no
point even even
making this observation anymore but i
will the double standard here is
is quite um quite apparent
i thought what we've heard from the left
for so long is
you know someone's private life is their
private life
who the the people they choose to be in
a sexual relationship with
that's up to them right consenting
adults
so who are you to have any opinion at
all about this
if if he says this is the lifestyle that
he wants to lead now
we're supposed to accept that who are
you to have any opinion or to say
no i don't really think i don't think
that's true i don't think he's right
about his own orientation
i mean the arrogance is
pretty astounding yeah you can't see
inside someone's heart and mind to know
they're real but that's that's true for
milo that's true for anybody
i can't see inside you can't see inside
my heart and mind you know my what my
motivations are i don't know what your
motivations are
and that's precisely the point here
uh number four and of course
mixed in with uh with this reaction this
mixed into the reaction to the story
about milo there's also a lot of
anti-catholic stuff thrown into it
because he says he's consecrating his
life to saint joseph
which is a perfectly wonderful thing for
anyone to do and so there's a lot of
anti-catholic bigotry being tossed into
it as well
all right number four taylor lorenz
journalist the new york times has gotten
some attention
recently for some claims that she's made
about the ways that online harassment
have impacted her so she tweeted this on
international women's day which
hopefully as you know a couple days ago
i hope that you commemorated and
celebrated it as
as i did she said for international
women's day please consider supporting
women enduring online harassment
it's not an exaggeration to say that the
harassment and smirk campaign i've had
to endure over the past year
has destroyed my life no one should have
to go through this it's not
it's not an exaggeration taylor are you
sure about that
i think it is it sounds like an
exaggeration to me she says i'm slightly
open about some of what i deal with but
the scope of attacks has been
unimaginable
there's no escape it's taken everything
from me
the only mild solace i've found with is
with other women
who have had their lives destroyed in
the same way we've developed
deep trauma bonds
deep trauma bonds um because
by the way the trauma bonds sounds like
maybe like a an indie band
anyway i'll return to that later um
trauma because of mean comments on the
internet
and this is what you so often get from
feminists especially
feminist journalists where they really
seem to believe this is not a put on
much of what they're doing here is much
of this is performative
but the part that's not performing is i
i think she really believes
that she is uniquely suffering this
or at least that women and especially
women journalists uniquely suffer this
kind of thing
it doesn't happen to the rest of us
certainly doesn't happen to men
men never have to endure any of this
no men anyone in the public eye
i'm not saying it's a good thing i have
no doubt that taylor lorenz gets a lot
of really mean comments
really vile comments i have no doubt
about that
i'm sure she gets many messages that are
that may be quite upsetting to her
i have no doubt now i have no doubt
because
i get that kind of stuff all the time
myself
most of the time it's not upsetting to
me because i don't allow myself to be
upset
and that's really what it comes down to
it's it's a question of
how are you going to respond to this
what is your reaction going to be
because you're going to get it on the
internet
all you can decide is how you'll respond
if it really has destroyed your life i
don't even know how that could be the
case
if it is the case that it's destroyed
your life then why don't you simply get
off the internet
and go do something else for a living
now i wouldn't normally say that you
should do something else for a living
simply to avoid
mean comments on the internet but if
you're saying it's destroyed your life
and caused trauma and you can't get over
it and it's unimaginable there's no
escape
well there is you know you know what the
escape is from from comments on the
internet
um the escape is this i'll show you
demonstration here's the escape watch
i'll show you
that's how you escape i'll show you
again if you're watching um so to escape
mean comments on the internet you do
this
put the phone down that's it and all of
that stuff is happening here
and i can put it down and live my life
that's the great thing this has happened
many times where people are attacking me
on twitter and
all of this stuff and it's so great that
i can just
click off put it down go read a book to
my kids
doesn't matter let the internet freak
out doesn't matter to me
so there is an escape but it happens to
all of us
um if if there's an impression that it
doesn't happen to men as often
i think the reason is that we don't talk
about it as much yo that has to be the
reason
i i don't go around talking about it all
the time and talking about how it's
destroyed my life doesn't mean it
doesn't happen
all right fine finally number five an
uber driver was assaulted by a group of
women
after he requested that one of them put
on a
a face mask now i'm not a big
fan of the mask thing as you know but i
fully respect a guy's right to tell you
the rules for riding in his car
fully respect that if you don't like it
get out of the car
really simple to me it's his car he has
every right to
to set the rules don't like it don't
ride in the car
she didn't like it this woman um but she
refused to get out of the out of the car
and instead she
communicated her um dislike for this
policy by
assaulting him let's watch that video
go
i think you get the idea there these
women these women are
surely scholars uh so
he he asked her to put the mask on she
didn't want to so she started coughing
in his face
ripped his mask off and tried to steal
his phone
perfectly reasonable reaction right
um and here she is now she she's not uh
she's not apologizing for that here she
is addressing this controversy
and kind of explaining why she reacted
the way that she did let's let's listen
my boyfriend
taught me he taught me don't let nobody
play with you smack
them that's what i was taught so if
y'all boyfriends
told y'all to let this uber let y'all
get out the car and
get robbed or whatever the [ __ ] would
have happened and i saw yo
hell no and he lucky as hell i ain't
have nothing on me on mamas because if
you would have played with me bro
it would have been a whole different
story for real you not about to kick me
on the freeway i
everybody i know 75 percent of people i
know would have smacked
it out of him or done some crazy off the
wall
all i did was smack take his mask off
and cough a little bit but i ain't even
have corona so at the end of the day
okay sorry i just i get so wrapped up
listening to her because she's so
eloquent
um and i i i just enjoy listening to her
express her express herself in in in
that really poetic and profound way
um two two observations well number one
i i guess it's nice anyway there's a
little bit of chivalry going on here a
little bit of old-fashioned shiver
talking about
her boyfriend is teaching her the things
that her boyfriend teaches her
i think i'd prefer to hear like the
things that her father taught her it
sounds like maybe
there's there's a lack of that which is
which is how this happened in the first
place
well the other two the things number one
what you see here is female privilege
okay that she's she's walking around
saying i'll smack anyone i don't care
i'll smack you
well just about any man any any
any male over the age of like 12
could beat the hell out of her in a
second if they wanted to
but they're not going to for the most
part and so she knows that she can walk
around smacking whoever she wants
i mean we could be pretty sure that's
not the first time she's done that
and she smacked that guy who could
easily take her in a boxing match i'm
sure
but he didn't respond physically and he
knew this is female privilege because he
knew even though he was the one being
attacked
he knew that if he had responded
physically he'd be the one in jail
and she knows that he knows that and so
that's why she's assaulting him
female privilege um and
number two we need to talk a little bit
about dumb person privilege because what
you just saw there
this is why i always go back
to the need to weed out dumb people from
voting
that person right there probably votes
and that's exactly what we need to
address in this country
there is no hope for the future as long
as people like that are helping to
determine it
really simple fifth grade level civics
exam
she's not gonna pass that easily done
something to think about all right let's
move on now to reading the youtube
comments
first comment says matt is cynical
paranoid unwilling to take
responsibility pessimistic
uncaring overly cancel happy unfeeling
and completely awesome
well thank you for that but you also
forgot that i am ill-tempered so make
sure to
put that in there nick miller says i'm a
walshio-sexual i'm in love with the matt
walsh show i'll take that
you know if we're inventing sexualities
then uh that one
that that one needs its own pride flag
lindsey rhodes says matt do you think
the creation of all those genders are an
effort to regain some sort of
individuality by these people
the left is always trying to strip away
individuality and lump everyone into
broad categories is it really surprising
then the people would grasp at the
opportunity to distinguish themselves
the only way that the left has deemed
acceptable
totally crazy yes but not surprising to
me oh you've put your finger on it i
think that's exactly right
that's what drives a lot of this the
the need the desire to be an individual
which we all desire to be individuals
and to to
differentiate ourselves from the crowd
to assert ourselves individually
and this is what the way that they've
been conditioned to do that
and that's why we went through yesterday
some of the new the newer invented
sexualities
including allosexual i think that's what
it was allosexual
and that's a sexuality where if you're
sexually attracted
period if you have any sexual attraction
at all
to any individual person or any group of
people then you're an allosexual
and i looked it up there's even i
believe an allosexual pride flag
demisexual you know that's someone who
needs an emotional attachment
which again that's those that's women
okay women need emotional
attachment or really feel that
attraction um
and so the reason that we're making up
all these
sexualities is partly because there's
real privilege
in being included in the lg under the
lgbt umbrella
but also i think people yeah it makes
people feel like they're more of an
individual
they're more interesting you know it's
too boring you don't want to say that
you
uh you're simply a quote cisgender
straight person
you want to be a more complicated and
interesting person
with more gray areas
and obviously the irony is that in this
rush to be an individual and to be so
interesting they end up just like
everybody else
um little paulie says matt you're
missing the most important point about
blm they aren't harassing random people
on the street they're harassing random
white people on the street it's a racist
anti-white movement
i agree i don't think i've missed that
at all i think that's a point i've made
many times but certainly i agree
william ferrario says isn't cow cuddling
prohibited in leviticus
somewhere toward the back or in a
footnote or did moses just figure it
wasn't worth mentioning
well i don't know cow cuddling certainly
violates the spirit of many biblical
laws
i would think it's an attack on nature
an attack on god
you might say i mean god made cows
big and fat and slow and not so that you
could cuddle with them
but so that they could more easily be
slaughtered and turned into
quarter pounders with cheese amen
one of those moments of panic that you
might have in life that i know i've had
too many times to count is when you're
driving in a car
or you're on a plane or somewhere and
you start to get that motion sickness
you start to feel nauseous
and you're thinking oh my gosh am i
gonna am i gonna have to ask them to
pull over the plane so i can hurl
you don't wanna deal with that and
that's why i use relief band relief band
is the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wrist band that's been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively present
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraine
hangover
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more the product the great thing is
it's 100
drug free it's non-drowsy provides all
natural relief with zero side effects
for as long as needed the technology was
originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals and now
it's available to the public
and you got to try it relief ban is the
only over-the-counter
wearable device that's been used in
hospitals and oncology clinics to treat
nausea and vomiting
i use it it works i can testify to that
this new year and sure nausea is
never the reason to miss out on life's
important moments right now relief ban
has an exclusive offer just for matt
walsh listeners
if you go to reliefband.com and use
promo code walsh you'll receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30 day money back return
guarantee so head to r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use our promo code walsh for
20
off and you know on election night we
announced that candace owens would be
joining the daily wire with a new show
now the wait is finally over the moment
is here candace's new show
appropriately titled candace will
premiere next friday march 19th
you may remember candace from well many
things but we know
cardi b ranted about her criticizing
womp harry styles was upset when she
you know had the audacity to suggest
that maybe mention where dress is
all of that um we know that the candace
always has interesting things to say
which is why you gotta check out candice
it's gonna be exclusive
to daily wire members if you're not yet
a member go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code candice to get 25 off
again
that's dailywire.com subscribe use code
candace for 25
off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
just when you think we've made it to the
furthest reaches of cultural lunacy and
of the cowardice that enables that
lunacy
we find still deeper depths to plunge
winston marshall plays or did play
rather the banjo and the lead guitar for
mumford and sons a group
famous for being everyone's third
favorite band in the summer of 2011.
and this past weekend marshall ignited
controversy and accusations of bigotry
and nazism
by publicly confessing to having read a
book
yes the musician tweeted an endorsement
of journalist andy knows antifa expose
which is called by the way if you want
to pick it up unmasked
inside antifa's radical plan to destroy
democracy the tweet address to know said
finally had the time to read your
important book you're a brave man
that was it that was a tweet and it was
enough to set the cancel wheels
in motion fans the media fellow
musicians came out swinging labeling him
a racist calling for him to be fired
so on and so on and so forth they made
it clear that there is essentially no
difference between reading and enjoying
a book critical of antifa
and pledging allegiance to hitler after
reading mein kampf
to hint at even the mildest disagreement
with the most radical
fringes of the far left is to profess
far-right views
which is to be a bigot which is to
reveal yourself unworthy of inclusion in
civilized society
that's the formula clear and simple and
totally insane in fairness to the cancel
mob
we should say this is not marshall's
first infraction
he has in the past showed other ominous
signs of possessing a mind of his own
an article in the hollywood reporter
notes quote this is not the first time
marshall
and marshall and mumford and sons have
courted controversy for associating with
notorious right-wing personalities
back in 2018 the band invited canadian
academic jordan peterson
who has been accused of transphobia
misogyny and islamophobia
to visit their london studios after
pictures of peterson and members of the
band appeared on social media marshall
told a canadian radio station
i don't think having a photograph with
someone means you agree with everything
they say
primarily i'm interested in his
psychological stuff which i find very
interesting
there you have it one minute marshall is
taking a picture with a famous
psychologist
three years later he's reading a book i
mean the left could not allow this
dangerous dissident
a strike three if they didn't cancel him
now who knows what he'd do next he might
go out and misgender a potato head toy
you never know what this guy will do
um there's no telling what sort of
dastardly deeds this villain might get
up to
fortunately the cancel mob was um able
to ran him rein him in then without much
without much trouble after deleting the
offending tweet
and then apparently deleting all of his
other tweets so he deleted that tweet
and then and then it seems if you go to
his page
he deleted all all of his tweets along
with it
marshall then issued the standard order
to order apology
this is what he said in his statement
first of all you almost know exactly
what he's going to say
before you hear me say it but he said
over the past few days
i have come to better understand the
pain caused by the book i endorsed
i have offended not only a lot of people
i don't know but also those closest to
me including my bandmates
and for that i am truly sorry as a
result of my actions i am taking time
away from the band
to examine my blind spots for now please
know that i realize
how my endorsements have the potential
to be viewed as approvals of hateful
divisive behavior
i apologize as this was not at all my
intention
now if you thought you would live your
whole life and never encounter the
phrase pain
caused by the book i endorsed you were
sadly mistaken
indeed i feel it must be emphasized and
really cannot be emphasized enough that
this man is begging for forgiveness
and stepping down from his position
because he read and recommended a book
he has come to believe or at least is
pretending to believe
that his decision to read a book caused
not only offense but actual
damage to other human beings
prior to this the most the most pathetic
and deranged bit of groveling we'd ever
witnessed was
the bachelor host chris harrison's
apology for advocating forgiveness
winston marshall managed to show a level
of stomach churning obsequiousness
that out did even that and i have faith
that some brave pioneer will come along
in the very near future to debase
themselves and surrender their dignity
in such a way as to make marshall look
like davy crockett defending the alamo
by comparison
it's all for naught of course as always
the groveler gains nothing from his
masochistic performance
he is no less canceled at the end of it
the emotional blackmailers who demanded
an apology for something that did not
affect them or harm them to begin with
have no plans to actually accept that
apology like any schoolyard bully
they get off on the act of imposing
their will on another person
if you let yourself become a source of
this perverse high
they're going to keep coming back for
more hits
you can't get them to stop taking your
lunch money by giving them your lunch
money your only hope then is to stand up
for yourself
stand your ground refuse to play their
game
and to send that message with a punch in
the nose now admittedly in the case of
the cancel mob
this is much easier said than done
there's certainly no guarantee that
they'll
leave you alone just because you have
made it clear that you're not going to
be an easy target
it's quite possible that no matter how
you respond
they will still come and take your job
and your livelihood and your reputation
away
but the one thing they can't take is
your dignity
they can't take that that is something
that a man must
willfully forfeit if everything else is
taken from you
that that is you could take solace in
knowing that the abs
no one can take that from you ever
you have to give it up you have to offer
it
you have to say here you go here it is
winston marshall is not the first and
certainly won't be the last to offer up
his
dignity on a silver platter and get
nothing in return
and for that he's canceled and he is
doubly canceled for being a disgrace to
the banjo playing community which as you
know
i'm going to take that especially
personally so cancel again for that
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. the white
house stonewalls reporters on the record
number of illegal alien kids being held
in cages
right wing provocateur milo yiannopoulos
is now
ex-gay and the cuomo scandals get even
worse check it out on the michael
knowles show